[Applaudissements]
tarifs
qui est tu fais
m
plus
vas-y à l'égard de ce soir
c'est n'importe quoi tatata dvd c'est
bon c'est bon merci mon chéri versée
[Musique]
merci jaune et leur chasse est morte
jodelet c'est josé au printemps y avons
ajouté
tu vas tu veux aller voir les six
candidats à bien côté mois à côté de moi
l aune accéder enfin attendez à saint
joseph
oui à côté moi j'écoute étoiles à
brasilia bien entendu merci les gars et
verser les chéris attendant je vais à
côté de toi comme ça on fait le tour on
fait le dernier droit attention et josé
garcia en fait il fait ils s'amusent en
fête avec nous merci merci les chéris
toutes ces dernières le poste sur celui
des vélib idée m'a dit d'y aller les
barreaux
je
je ne garde pas savoir et où on se
retrouve à toucher au montant sera en
direct à la folie heureusement dans les
vacanciers et bien sûr du tout c'est
derrière l'hypothéquer loi était soigné
après à fond c'est le 21 décembre
je n'oublie pas la télé ce qu'est l'art
merci à john a
[Musique]